Guys, Darius went live today. Today is the day of his court hearing.
Okay, today is the day of Darius IRL's court hearing and he's
got a new suit.
>> Darius got a suit for his court date, >> Supposed
to be like eight. >> But yeah, I don't know why Darius
decided that he was going to film outside of the courtroom with
Zena there. I don't know why he made that decision. Cyber says
apparently the 6K law was for other stuff. >> Cuz he's
like providing evidence that he violated dumb ass uh the the
the temporary protection order. >> Yeah. I don't know why
you take a selfie
>> Now he's when it comes to streaming. So he's going to
have to move somewhere else. I don't Wait a minute.
>> All of this is going to be used against him in court.
That's what I'm saying. He's
He is
I forgot to put this up earlier.
I had a me
I forgot to put this up earlier. They're starting to actually
buy this. I've got them saying Beller Pros. Lol. All right. Good
night. Love you. Good work. Update me again tomorrow. Also, stop
telling me love you. Assan would never say that. Assan would
never say that back to Queen. What the? He would never say it.
Okay. Darius stuff. Darius stuff. It's Darius stuff time, guys.
Darius went live today. Today is the day of his court hearing.
Okay, today's the day of Darius IRL's court hearing. He is supposed
to go to court because of a what is it? It's a temporary So,
he has a temporary restraining order, temporary protective order
in Texas. And Zena is filing for a permanent protective order
as in Darius can't be in the same spaces as me. Darius can't
contact me. He's like an unhinged lunatic. He's like stalked
me places, right? So, he applied for this
and there are rules to the temporary protective order and he
applied for this and it's his hearing today. The temporary protective
order, I assume if he if he has, you know, if there's proof of
the things Zena is saying, he might have some trouble, but otherwise,
you know, they're going to have a court date and things will
be settled, right? Today's supposed to be the day. And he decided
to stream for some of it. Okay. So, he shows up for a stream
and he's got a new suit.
>> Darius got a suit for his court date, guys. to be like
a hole on suit. It's supposed to be like something more casual.
Something more casual where it looks like I'm taking it seriously,
but I'm not taking it too.
>> You know, it says that he's taking it really seriously.
The idea that he won't remove the tags, >> right? They're
they're they're skinny chinos. They're skinny chinos. What do
you mean they don't fit right? I just think black socks. Hold.
Let me get black socks. Black socks. He'll think differently.
Let me find black socks. >> Black socks would be better.
Find some black socks. We're just going to go through each of
his bods here. See what he's doing. He's getting dressed up.
He's getting dressed up. >> So doesn't care either. So
it is what it >> Apparently wearing a drag. Oh, Kger. If
Kger is out there, if Kger is somewhere, Kger, can you hear me?
Kger, do you have the the video of him getting MK to contact
Zena last night? Do we have that video somewhere? Can I find
that? Can we find that video somewhere? I've heard that this
exists that apparently the theory is that Merc contacts Zena
to talk on behalf of Darius. This is the theory. This is the
unhinged schizophrenic theory, guys.
not my not my wheelhouse. Uh, I'll post >> He's going to
wear that. He does not wear this. >> Uh, if he can if he
be annoying about it, you guys can just bother him with >> Rich
just said he had nothing to do with that. Okay. >> And
a pretty big snake. Uh, he keeps saying he's not confrontational.
The reality is he is confrontational. He just wants to hang out
the mob. So, you want to hang out the mob, that's fine. But,
uh, is Yeah, we all know you've been cheating.
>> Oops. That's a violation of an OFP.
>> Wait, is this what a [__] that still breaks
the TRO? So, I'm not sure how he broke the TRO or if this was
it or the merc thing was it? But I do know he breaks it later
for sure >> or whatever it is. >> Uh, his obvious
girlfriend,
uh, wherever she is. >> Give me two seconds. You need to
be right back. >> Take the shirt off. people that I don't
have another shirt, so it's pretty much going to be it.
I watched that stream D10 turn on the charm of Danny forgave
him. He admitted to it. So, what's up? Post some shots. Um, I
really don't need to be fighting more than I already am. Uh,
if he continues to annoy the out of me, I'll do it. Um, if he
continues to Uh, yeah, that's pretty much it. If he continue
to annoy the [__] out of me, I'll
>> Oh, hold on. I just realized I can go get all of Otoshara's
logs for my Discord. Oh, hello. I'm back, by the way. I might
go Hold on. Let me Let me call up one of the homies.
See if we can see we put in a request. Give me a >> Oh,
we're listening to Darius. Hold on. Let me see if he
>> see what he's doing here. >> I think it's a hearing
on should be granted and then we have to just go into a fight
about why it should be granted.
dress shirt with a tie. I don't have that, unfortunately. There's
a dress shirt that would have came with this, but I was I came
when they were clothing, so I don't have time to try it on. All
right, let's try with this. >> All right, I'm back. >> Is
that better? >> Oh, does he wear the black shirt? I don't know
if that works as well. Oh, yay. Going to a funeral. What's going
>> Going back and forth. >> Okay, hold on. Where
we
>> go to this one? Right. >> Worst case happens.
This one. I'm just going to scroll through a bunch of these VODs
for
>> Oh, that is this one. This one. This one's the next
one. >> We're just going to go through each of these cuz
he goes and walks around a little bit. Talks about
Yeah. It's not really my my
blazer. I didn't bring a freaking uh sticky thing. >> Looks
like he aged 20 years of the last 6 months. Ah, man. I don't
know. I don't think the shaved head looks that bad. He looks
older,
>> but I don't think he looks like bad or anything. I don't
know. I don't I don't feel like I need to talk this guy. I don't
need that to feel good about myself. You guys got to do that.
You go >> I think he looks like awful or >> You see
Mer Press, you know? Yeah. It's not really my my my monkey or
my circus,
>> Okay.
Uhhuh.
>> Why are you pretending that you aren't involved? They
both have like criminal allegations against you. They both have
like open charges against you. What do you mean? Not my monkey,
not my circus.
What the What the are you saying? >> Why is Dan Why is
Dan here?
>> I thought Dan was here to not pick a >> Why is
>> Why is Why is Dan here? And also, why is she here?
>> So, that's probably a good idea of like, hey, uhoh,
why is D10 here? Why is she here? I think probably this is around
the time you shut the stream off, right? Oh, [__]
At least the hearing streaming right now. >> Go to the
bathroom and joker makeup
>> Let's fight detail next. >> This is a court hearing
for criminal charges. No, it is not a court hearing for criminal
charges. It is a court hearing to resolve whether or not a protective
order should be granted against Darius for Zena. Zena has filed
for a protective order against Darius, citing things like him
stalking her at what was it? Kitcon in Dallas
and a couple other things. Right. Now, the Kickon Dallas stuff,
Darius was unhinged, chasing her down as Right. Some of the other
things, I don't know how one-sided it was, but she like lots
of the things she was saying, lots of the things she alleges
those are true. Now, is there some two-sided parts to them? Maybe
Ollie kickflip 91. Thank you very much for the 20 months, almost
two years, buddy. Thank you. Thank you. So, I think a lot of
the things she alleges are very true. How true, like, or how
one-sided they are, I'm not sure. And I guess we'll look through
them on
on balance. Definitely Darius is the one chasing her around the
backyard, spitting in her face, right? Like there are a lot of
instances where Darius is the person initi initiating things
physically or like doing the assaults, doing all the crimes.
So I do think the clips speak quite poorly for him.
And we'll we'll see how it goes. I don't know. Uh we're just
going to keep watching. I'm trying not to spoil for the people
who are unaware of baby mama has enough of that. >> That's
her witness. her witness at Dream
>> What is Nita gonna say? I I was stalking her. What?
>> Yeah, probably. Cuz you were totally trying him.
>> Drop the Addie. I don't condone anybody
harassing or bothering anybody else and I hope you guys don't.
I'm just vlogging my experience. >> Okay. Well, that's
a smart thing to put on tape at least. Still probably shouldn't
be recording right now. >> She's bringing people. Yeah,
she's bringing what's it called? Should I have brought prawn?
Like wouldn't that >> how much does the restraining order
care about if the abuse is two ways? I would guess probably um
that
uh how would we put this? I would guess that it would be a mitigating
factor if the other person like you can't say I need a protective
order from this person if you are consistently re-engaging with
them and entering their spaces, right? I think that would probably
be not not necessarily as effective. Like if if I would say Zena
continue to re-engage and like start escalating in front of him,
I would say that would probably be something that would be maybe
excing
people. I was told when I was most consulted when I consulted
with the lawyer, they said just come in and
talk about stuff. And then Zena went to Darius house with a mace
and a taser and tear gas. Did she use the mace or the taser or
the tear gas on Darius or what happened? Yes. Was that before
or after Darius spit in her face multiple times? Was it before
or after?
Was it before or after? Oh, after.
Should we use the mace on him? It's his house. After it's his
house. Okay. I'm just going to tell you that if you chase somebody
around spitting on them, and then physically assault them,
probably you're going to have a hard time arguing while they
had mace. I think >> then after that, you're going to have
another court date.
>> I'm not really sure what the MO is here. Bringing DJ
in. >> Yeah, Nick, no spoilers. What are you >> Maybe
a free car ride. >> I swear to God, these people come in
and they're like, "Oh man, you guys are watching seven."
It's crazy when when uh Brad Pitt's wife is her head is in that
box at the end, right? That's crazy.
Are you serious right now? What are you
Why Why do people come in? What makes people do this? >> I
never I can think of like
Are you bullied? Are you being swollen? Hi, I'm Marine.
>> Come in halfway through Fight Club. Can you believe
he's hallucinating that guy the whole time? Did you know that?
Did he's He is right now. >> How are you?
>> You already passed it in his stream. I did not, Nick.
No, I did not. This is like literally hours before the clip you
were referring to.
>> I don't know if you know. So, >> no. No, you still
have to watch it,
Jerry's trying to get out of watching Fight Club. Not allowed.
Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope.
>> Is that even allowed?
>> Wait, what was in the box? Don't worry. What's in the
box, man? I just named two Brad Pit movies, too. >> Can
we have V ride? I don't think she even wants to be involved cuz
he's a
>> We don't get hurt today. >> Oh, no. I think she
>> also fought and did illegal stuff during it and didn't
do anything. Okay. Um, >> Shuy would be if Shubi didn't
also have mace and weapons and if I get him in trouble. Oh my
god, the logic is logicing. The logic is logicing, bro.
>> This go to jail. This guy's going to jail. Oh my god.
The logic is logicing. Wait, wait. This guy had a weap Oh my
god. This guy's like a felon. The logic is logicking. This going
to jail. This guy is done. >> Come on the way, bro. >> He's
a witness, too. We got some
[__] coming. That's crazy that you guys weren't wrong.
>> Is anyone's blood? Too bad I'm go as
free in pocket.
>> I don't know about that.
>> Look, Dan wasn't choosing sides. I mean, he probably
picked a side after he uh,
>> you know, exposed that he was cheating on his girlfriend
>> while he was like
>> hanging out with my roommate.
That's funny that Zena also hangs out with cheaters.
>> that's why I hating it so much. >> Did he not
hire an attorney? They didn't bring attorneys to this or I don't
think Darius brought an attorney to this,
>> So, I don't know how long they sit here. Roughly the
same place.
>> Bunch of lawyer fees. Like 12,000 for
>> 6,000 just for the stuff.
I don't think ICE came to help him.
>> Shouldn't need an attorney for the initial hearing of
a protection order, which makes me curious how heed this up.
>> Okay. Well, he's sitting here. Wait,
>> It It cuts in and out a lot. He goes to 7-Eleven eventually.
We going to 7-Eleven now? I think we're going to 7-Eleven right
now.
Lau Darius did a consultation and the lawyer saw him looking
like a henchman for Blade and was going like, "No, bro. You don't
need my help. Just go in there and talk." Oh boy. Henchman from
Blade goes hard though.
>> Trust me,
>> not even Blade one. Like Blade 2, Blade 3. Okay. Not
even Blade 1. Was this all today? It was all today. Bro, how
does that hit so hard? He looks like somebody who's like next
to the the villain in Blade. Absolutely.
Fact that D10 is there >> is absolutely insane. Absolutely
insane. >> DK got so angry
that I leak.
>> Is that Austin? Yeah. So, apparently there's another
streamer there with Zena and Darius is getting pretty upset about
>> Is Miss Andrew
No way D10 is there.
>> What is D10 doing? I think he's here to talk about Dream
Hack
and he's claiming that I was stalking her. I don't know what
he's I don't know what the point of that would be. >> That's
rough that they brought a witness. You didn't bring a witness.
>> They just went there alone. No squeeze her other roommate.
Apparently, yes, he just went there alone. How long do you guys
genuinely think he'll be locked up for? Like 24 hours.
>> I don't I don't think I think he'll he'll get bailed.
They won't they won't keep him there a long time. >> It's
just like he needs to be penalized for breaking the uh what do
you call it? the protective order
her company on a car and driving off. I have no reason to bring
up that she has a pass. I just need to show her poor.
>> Wait longer. He broke bail conditions. I don't know
if he I don't think he broke bail condition. I got to go to I
don't even know what your name is. I don't think he broke bail
conditions. I think that he I think it was a violation of the
protective order. Or maybe you can be put under protective order
cuz you're on bail. Maybe there is like some crossover. But it
does talk about a protective order. And I do think there's a
good chance he actually broke the protective order.
>> He's a weirdo for that. He doesn't care. He's already
labeled. >> Mer called the jail.
>> Can we get a Can we get a time stamp for that call,
please? Okay. So, Darius is sitting here.
We'll keep this in mind. This location. Okay. He's sitting here.
He's ora farming. He's looking around.
Sitting here. Sitting here. Sitting here. I believe he eventually
goes, "I'm thirsty.
I'm going.
to 7-Eleven.
>> I don't think that timeline exists. If that timeline
exists, Chinese agent where Darius could have been the VP of
customer engineering at Apple. >> If that that's like the
that's like the Doctor Strange one in 11 trillion timeline. Okay,
>> I'm going to go inside and see what's up. See how far
along we are.
You got to be trolling, right? >> He does leave to go get
a pop. Hold on. Where where's it at? Where's it at? He was saying,
"I don't with the negativity while literally hanging out with
like the source of like everyone's problems the last like eight
months."
>> I got it, Hattie Bn. I got it. Don't worry. I got it.
So, where are we here? When's he going to When's he going to
Sav? He goes to 7-Eleven. I swear to God he does. >> There's
no way I hallucinated him going to 7-Eleven, is there?
>> yeah. Right now. Okay. >> We've had this game.
Okay. >> Here we go. Here we go. Who's he talking to?
>> Somebody comes over and talks.
>> Hey, how are you? I'm >> good. So, here in the
public area, you can do everything.
>> Okay. I will just let you know right >> We've
had this. Okay. >> Okay. 100%. Got you. Thank you. Yeah,
I agree.
>> They of course they they they talked to him. I knew
they talked to him. >> So they're telling Darius something
about like no pictures or whatever,
>> That's what it said there, I believe. Yeah. No pictures.
No, don't do >> And and they they showed him the picture.
They showed him the picture, too. That's so funny.
>> Wait, what picture did they show him?
>> No, they didn't tell him to stop recording, I don't
think. >> Nice try though, dog. >> Yeah, pensive
goat. I assumed. So I put in my tweet about this that he's filming
in like a public area. So I do believe you can film in a public
area.
>> You should ask for your own RO.
>> Uh that's the legal plan. I think I'm going to ask
>> I think I might ask for a continuence.
We'll see. Move the hairs. I know we can move the hairs, bro.
>> Okay, here we go. Walks outside.
>> He's going. He ends up in 7-Eleven
or some other convenience store. I'm not even sure. >> You
guys have like
a 7-Eleven. No way. He's going for deodorant. Got to make a good
impression on the judge. Guys, >> be right here. Right.
>> That's funny. That's really funny.
>> you pay like 10 grand for a lawyer or we >> Here,
I'll back it up. >> Trying to figure out if we either continue
this and pay like 10 grand for a lawyer or we have what we need.
I kind of want I don't know. I don't think right now it could
get granted based off the information. It would it would have
to be another hearing afterwards
because she's obviously going to ask for it to continue. Now
she's going to have Dan talk about work yesterday. Well, DT I
don't think Dan can I don't even know what the point of DT adding
himself would be. It's just so
>> it's like so >> I know Top Bronson. That's what
I was thinking as well. Hold on a second. That's exactly what
I was like very not sure about. Oh,
do I have multiple instances of kick right now? God damn it.
I'm getting like double ups. Oh, that's why I'm getting double-
ups. Okay. No, we're good. We're good. We're good. We're good.
We're good. We're good. No more double-ups.
Yeah, like he's he can't he's keeping the tag on so he can return
it, I guess. >> So, I'm trying to figure out what the is
>> It's kind of >> What's the point of Dan being
there? >> Like Dan can't he speak? I don't think he can
speak. >> Pron said he wanted to return it. All right.
That's crazy.
>> I have to I have to find out. Dan just said he's observing.
No, he did not. >> You check the clips. He talks about
the tag. I say that. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Hold on. Let me go let me go look at this chat right
now cuz I am Wait, wait, wait. What? Wait. Who posted that photo
where? There's no way Darius posted a photo of Zena in his Discord,
right? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What? Hold on. >> He
said that on
going to be sitting in the corner. >> Oh, if anyone wants
to just come and then observe, you can. I guess I guess anyone
could just observe. I'll let you in. Come on. >> Should
be posted the photo from inside the courtroom. Observe. Come
on over. Let me know. >> Hey, cowboy here. Did you want
to observe, Ralph?
>> So, how did they figure out that Darius took the photo?
Wait, hold on. Country captain, do you believe that Darius wouldn't
have taken that photo? No. Had he been, I was asking for the
clips from last night. Was asking for it. Let's see it. Doesn't
he make a lot of funny money? He does. Jesus Christ. Okay, we're
on to the final VOD here,
I
Okay, we're on to the final VOD. Here it comes. Daryus comes
back. He sits down. He's got his banana now. Okay.
>> he's chilling. He's chilling.
>> Now, here's the one thing that we thought was a big
deal, but maybe isn't a big deal, right?
>> Is he sitting here? >> Really nice. >> Then
eventually you have Zena and the other person come in, right?
That should be Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. >> Trying
to do something. And I say like, "Do you want to have it granted
or?" >> No, there's no way. There's no way he deleted that
VOD there. Hold on. Hold
>> Oh, did he delete his last VOD? Oh, he deleted his last
VOD. You son of a Hold on. Hold on.
>> This This
is not real.
What is he doing? What am I getting sound from? Hello. Hello.
Hello. Hello. Hello. Yeah, it's kick. Okay, let me get my Where's
my Darius IRL? The brother delete his last VOD. Oh no, hold on.
Wait. No way. Hold on.
What am I missing? I'm missing one of the VODs here now. I had
these all earlier. What the happened? What
>> I could have sworn it was this VOD that we have Zena
and the other guy sitting in. Was it not the last VOD?
Zena has also received a >> Was it this one? Oh, it'll
be like this one maybe.
>> I swear to God, I watched this earlier. I literally
pulled this VOD up and watched it. How the is this go? Oh, somebody
could have gone on his computer, right? No, no, no. Somebody
could have gone on his computer and taken it down. Do you have
the photo yet? No. Somebody throw the photo in the Discord or
something. Or where is it?
This is the photo. Oh, this isn't in the courtroom, though. This
is of them outside, right? If this is the photo he took, he also
had them on stream the same way. D10 and Zena. That's the photo
there. I thought it was a photo from inside the courtroom.
Also, if anybody if some if anybody asks how this could possibly
be a thing.
Hold on. Actually, I don't even know if I can trust this guy
linking the same one.
Wait, what? Your album is gone.
Guy who just linked?
>> Jeez, Beef, your album's gone.
Shuy totally took that. Yeah, I don't think so. But that's outside.
That's That's these same like chairs and Dude, I swear to God
there was a VOD.
How do I figure out what I'm doing here? Unless
Unless Oh no, it is this VOD. Wait, hold on. Which one is this?
Give me a second. It's like this one. >> I still hold strong.
Isn't it bring up the wind? >> Dude, what is happening?
It was this one, right? Sorry. Just give me a second.
I'll figure it out. It's this one. No, this one is gone. Oh,
it's deleted. This fault is deleted. The one with Zena in it
is deleted from his account.
That's crazy. I don't know how he deleted it. Oh no. This is
it. What the Okay.
I don't know what's going on with everything going on right now.
I don't know what's going on, but this is it right here. Okay.
So, he sets himself up at the start of his stream. And this is
Zena right here. So, this is the stream and these are the photos,
right?
So, you said he posted a photo. The photo is the same thing is
exactly what's going on here. And then he turns on his live stream.
Okay, you may have been correct, Nick. You may have been
>> Apparently, I watched this the wrong order this morning,
but this is the one. >> We're going to get live here.
>> Look good. Thank you. I appreciate it. Got this. Ralph
Lauren.
>> Okay, so he is Yes. trolling >> pretty good. >> He
is like aura farming. Okay.
Just It's not just a still from the stream. It's different. This
is definitely not a still from the stream. This is him holding
his phone up.
>> Nice to meet you. Ready to activate.
>> Oh, this is the Sorry. This is like the actual picture
of like D10 looking back at me. Like, is this like recording
right now? There's no way.
He's mewing super hard. This is the This is going back to the
tweet. Okay. All right. We're finally going back to the tweet
today.
Darius arrested. So,
I like the way I put this. Okay.
Darius in court today for his protective order. Streamed in the
courthouse. public areas with Zena in frame. I don't know which
way the hearing went, but
seems to have been arrested for violating the temporary protective
order that was in place before the hearing. He is arrested
violation of bond or protective order. 3:52 p.m. So that would
have been Yeah. later in the day. It's not violating protective
order if they're both there for court, right? It's I believe
streaming it is what is violating a protective order, right?
I believe creating content, taking pictures, doing this. I believe
this is the violation of the protective order. So, this would
have been a part of the temporary protective order, right? So,
what do we got here? Let me pull over my let me pull over my
album here. So, somebody at Zena and says, "Didn't he just stream
while sitting behind you?" Zena says, "The judge and deputies
already know. God is good. Take care, everyone. Chat with you
soon." Darius gets arrested. Okay. And then somebody from Shuy's
Discord or in the CX Discord post Shuy logs he violated by streaming
and sitting next to them in court and taking pics of them in
the courtroom. So, I think this is outside of the courtroom,
but apparently this is what it is. So, he starts his stream,
he's right next to them, and he streams and then he takes pictures,
right? So, he's got the he's got the selfie that we just looked
at, this guy. And at the very beginning of the stream, he sets
up like this stream starts with them sitting there, right?
Pull it back to where it cuts in. So, black screen, black screen,
black
black screen, black screen, black screen. Kicks in and they're
there. He's like setting it up. Is he spending the night in jail?
He might be spending more than one night in jail.
Hold on. Where was the uh Was it It wasn't cheese beef. It was
Who sent the clip? Where's the merc clip at? Hold on. Let me
Let me go find the merk clip. Where the merc clip at? Clips
past day. >> You're trying to prevent his demise.
>> Okay. And how are you doing that, sir? The best way
to do it is to not get >> Fly in my face. Kogan style.
Thank you. >> I laugh when they sent random
>> Kogan style. Thank you.
>> He's booked in for a violation of bond or a protective
order.
>> He has not seen a magistrate yet. So he he just got
here.
>> Do you know when he's possibly going? >> So is
that is he waiting to get arraigned right now? Is that what it
is? He's he's detained. He's got to get arraigned so he can go
and like get processed and kicked out. Normally it takes 18 to
24 hours to see the judge um with a class A misdemeanor is what
he has. So um it just depends when they get to his name on the
docket. >> Gotcha. Um and he's unable to have visitors
at this moment, right? Since he's just gotten in. >> Yes,
he he just got here. He's located at a temporary housing facility.
If he stays longer than the two to three days here at the downtown
Joe and gets moved to Dell Valley, then he will have visitation
there. >> Awesome. Thank you so much. I appreciate
>> Bye. See, I know he would get transferred. I really
hope he doesn't get transferred because >> that's a little
crazy.
>> That's a little crazy.
People keep spamming one year minimum. I don't think that's real.
Should we cook and merc
video? We get a time stamp here. We do. Apparently, Murk went
and pressed Zena and Shi last night.
So, I don't know what this was all about. Check out some of this
is all MK's stream.
She goes and rolls up with them
>> Wait, I thought Darius just hired a lawyer for 6K. Now
he's in jail because his dumbass refuses to hire a lawyer. Apparently,
Tree something like this. I just realized I'm also not in the
Discord. So, even if Tree was wanting to join or something, I'm
literally not in the Discord right now. Sorry, I get used to
streaming without the Discord open sometimes. I don't know if
Tree wanted to hop on. I don't know what you're doing, Tree.
Sorry, I was not in the Discord at all. Wasn't even thinking
about it. So,
>> but yeah, I don't know why Darius decided that he was
going to film outside of the courtroom with Zena there. I don't
know why he made that decision. Cyber says, "Apparently, the
6K lawyer was for other stuff. I've not been keeping up as much
with these guys, to be honest. GoFundMe to stop false
Support my legal fund and stop false narratives. God damn it.
I can't copy out of this chat very well. What?
Let's check this out. Why? Why did pro Why would Darius do that?
Why would Darius process like this?
That's crazy.
$90 raised, $45,000 goal. Support my legal fund. Hey team, as
some of you already know, I've gotten myself into a bit of legal
trouble. Darius makes $1,000 a day. Do not give him money. Darius
makes $1,000 a day. Do not give him money. Darius makes $1,000
a day. Do not give him money. for this. You can you can donate
to him if you want, but don't give him money for this. Don't
give him money for his stupidity.
As some of you already know, I've gotten myself into a bit of
legal trouble. As you guys know, I'm not the brightest and sometimes
say things that are probably not needed to be said. So, with
that said, period, I'm currently looking for funds to support
exclusively my legal battles as the cost of all of this has become
a lot lately. I'd like to go to I'd like to continue using the
funds I make for from producing content to be used on making
more content rather than spending it on things that I can't really
involve you guys in. This GoFundMe is not to discredit anyone.
It is to make sure I can afford a lawyer that can defend my side
as well as possible and assure everyone is
Wow. Wow. Not making dollars sitting the slammer, my guy. Well,
well,
still pay out to Viewbots. I don't think Darius Viewbots like
I I don't know man. I look at Darius's engagement. It looks so
much more Darius had like 10% of this engagement that he has
now
with like a quarter of the viewers,
right? Like he had he had nowhere near like his engagement went
way up like way more than his viewership went up viewership went
up. Sometimes it like drops off a little bit but I thought I
thought he he picked up engagement a lot. His 30K a month streaming
budget goes fast. I heard he bought a go-kart then returned it.
I just don't know how long this will continue, right? I have
no idea how long this will continue with like kick funding people
just breaking the law all over the place. Seems like it won't
can't last forever, right? Oh,
this is the photo. This is the photo of D10 and Zena in the courtroom
that apparently they're saying Darius took. Now, I didn't see
Shuy around the courtroom, right? So, I don't know who else could
have taken this picture or who would have taken this picture.
There's a picture of D10 and Zena in the courtroom. So, this
would be bad, right? This would be really, really stupid to do.
Hey, this guy is like harassing me. Now, he took a picture and
posted in his Discord. There's no way Darius posted this photo
in his Discord, right?
That can't be possible. There's no way.
There's no way Darius would post this in his Discord.
He did not. I Yeah, I wouldn't believe that he did.
>> But did he send this to other people in
>> Would it get posted and from who? Seems easy to figure
out if it was not Darius or not. That's what you would think.
>> Been trying to find out all day. All
>> Who's that? It's D10. D10 man B and and
What's up, Tree? How's it going?
Hello. Hello. Your mic is currently
>> Damn it. >> There we go. >> Can you hear
me now? >> I can hear you now. How's it going?
>> Hey, how are you?
>> Pretty good. About you. >> So, him streaming her.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Hold on. How's it going? Do the pleasantries
for It's fine. Sorry. So, him streaming her. Go >> That
was a violation. But with him, see Darius, this is what I'm saying.
Somebody should have told his dumb ass, you should have showed
up there with a lawyer. He would have never let you put the stream
on in the first place as soon as you walked into the courtroom.
I mean, uh, sorry, in the lobby. As soon as you walked into the
lobby, he would have made you like, "No, you can't record nothing."
Because
first of all, he's already on a temporary u temporary order.
He shouldn't have sat that close to her, right? He can like like
he is purposely antagonizing her. She's going to win a permanent
court order because of what he did. You could tell he's trolling.
Like you see her in the background. She's not even turning around.
He sits there purposely stands up start uh talking about his
suit and this that and the other. But there's so many benches
there. He purposely sat there as a means of getting her in the
back shot. That right there, whether he sent that picture, I'm
not sure. But the the the streaming is already a
>> Didn't have to sit there, but he did
because he saw her there.
>> I So he was, I think, sitting there a little bit earlier
as well, but like he did go back. He clearly didn't have his
stream on and then they were sitting there and then he turns
his stream on and they're sitting there, right? Like it's like
he clearly made the decision, okay, I know they're sitting there
and now I'm going to turn the stream on. So yes, I I agree basically
totally.
>> Uh as far as the as far as the stream is concerned,
let's say for instance because we don't know let's say for instance
she was not sitting there. Let's we'll play that game, right?
Let's say for instance she was not sitting there and he was sitting
there and then he got up to go to the bathroom. She's sitting
there. Now he turns the the camera on. He did not have to sit
there directly behind her with her in the view of the stream
with him getting loud and also bringing attention to himself
in hopes that she would turn around because if we can see her
in his stream,
he violated the court order.
And not only that though, but that just proves my point about
how you don't want this permanent. If he comes out the bathroom
with the scenario we just said and she's sitting there, he got
to sit somewhere else away from her because he's still under
the he was served the temporary protection order. I promise you
that stream is one of the thing maybe the picture too, but that
stream is the first offense of him violating the protection order.
And had he came there with a lawyer, the lawyer would have been
the father and said, "No, son. We're not turning on the camera.
>> I don't know why you'd risk it. >> Yeah. I just
don't know why you'd risk it because apparently she also included
>> Well, I think she included Shuy on like one of the applications
as a housemmaid, I heard. So, like actually it'll be a protective
order for both her and Shuy, I think. Like there's some way you
can say this is my partner and also it like functions for them
as well. So, like if this gets made permanent with that being
the case, I don't know how he does content in Austin right now,
>> right guys? Um,
>> it seems like crazy to me. >> I didn't know that
that was new information you just gave me about Shivi being on
the the court papers. I thought it was just >> I heard
that. That's what people said that like apparently Shuy got added
as like a partner and apparently that makes it apply equally
to both of them.
>> I haven't looked into that. That is what I've heard
of it. >> He Yeah, he he would have to stay away. She was
the one who was violated. She's the one who, you know, was spit
on several times. You know, she She's the one who had her name
from what I saw on the paperwork. I didn't That's what I'm saying.
Like he's on there. I didn't see that. So, she's the victim and
if she's the victim,
um the
temporary, possibly permanent with the fact that he got locked
up for vi the fact that he got locked up for violating the temporary
protection order guarantees her to get a permanent protection
order. He's because and my thing is vibe. That's how I see it,
too. Sorry, I was just going to agree. >> He's in jail
right now, right? Okay. So, if he's in jail right now and he
was in jail for violating the temporary protection order,
then he then it just goes to show you that he can't follow orders.
The judge does not look favorably about like on that. You know
what I'm saying? And with so many male and this is a statistical
criminal stat statistical fact of how many women are
or assaulted under men that they file temporary protection orders
against. They violate them anyway cuz they don't take them as
a joke. Judges never forget that and they go, "Oh, you can't
even take this [__] seriously as a temporary protection
order. So, let me put some heavy restrictions on there and make
that [__] permanent.
>> Yeah. I just feel like Yeah. I feel like you'd have
to be shown to be complet like if he could show up to that or
uh that hearing and say Zena is completely lying somehow, maybe
he could get out of the permanent protection order or protective
order, right? Maybe.
But like Zena is not lying. She might be like slightly stretching
some facts about who was like chasing down who in some situations.
You're saying like you're saying regardless of the of the how
of him violating this if he can show that the probable >> show
is totally fake >> but it's like it's not totally fake
and we all know it's not totally fake like she has very compelling
on his side. >> Yeah, she can cuz we saw it, right? So
no this he's so because one he didn't get a lawyer and two why
would you do that? I I really want to understand
his mind and his thinking process of yeah, there's Zena. Let
me go ahead and sit directly behind her, even though the temporary
protection order told me to stay certain amount of feet away
from her. There's several benches I can sit at. Let me sit at
the one right right behind her. That's a good idea. And turn
my camera on on the other bench that I supposed to be sitting
on.
I could say though like
like W content I guess he's like making content for us. We get
to sit here and laugh. I don't know.
>> I can't I can't hate him too much for this, right? I
can't I can't be like, "Oh, this is really terrible for me. I
just get to sit here and like watch it happen." And >> I
I guess I just don't understand why throw your life away
for content in as far as he's concerned and you're throwing it
away for a woman that you have a lovehate relationship with.
cuz it's fair to say that Zena is is about goddamn time and she
is over Darius and maybe it took him like really spitting on
her so many times for her to finally get the message. I don't
know.
Um I thought getting hit upside the head with several times would
have be it or you know say what I don't know like or being thrown
in what was that Japan or some place or >> Yeah. Like I
thought that I I guess getting your ass kicked was not like a
sign. And she kicked his ass, too. Don't get me wrong. I'm not
saying this that that she's the innocent one. What I'm saying
is that like it took it took the spitting for you to say, "Yeah,
I think I'm I'm done with Darius." But I don't think Darius is
done with her. I I think >> I don't know if she's done
to be honest with you. I just I straight up don't know if she's
done. I just don't know, man. I don't know. Yeah, she Well,
I think she's done. However, let's say I'm wrong. It's too late
now. She can't violate her own uh permanent uh because I'm going
just go ahead and say permanent protect protection order. Okay,
I'm already going to call it right now because of what his actions
at on today today at court. It's gonna Yeah. They're gonna have
another court hearing and uh whether he's in jail or not. Not.
He has to justify
why he filmed live streamed her. She's a live streamer. She didn't
live stream it at all. Why he live streamed her sitting behind
her knowing it was her in that >> One second. Hold on.
Princess, would you want to hop on the stream?
There's Darius's current roommate. If you want to hop on the
stream, just I would have like a couple questions. I feel like
you could fill in some blanks for us for sure. I Sorry. This
would just be very entertaining, I think. >> No, no, no.
That's No, that's >> Sorry. You continue. So, he's going
to have to explain like why he
I guess like all of his actions that are on clips, right? That's
what you're saying. >> No, no. He No, the judge is going
to want to know the first thing of why he's in jail because he
violated a temporary protection order. He has to justify that
before he gets into the actual case because that right now
is the reason why like like this is going to determine whether
it's going to be permanent. Is that the Bronze guy? >> That's
uh yeah, Pronto is Darius's roommate, Bronos. What's up, Bronto?
>> Nice to meet you. >> Hi, nice to meet you. >> Yeah,
I covered this a little bit earlier I ended my stream. Okay.
I think probably the big question we have is do you know if he
took this photo and do you have a like an opposing theory for
who could have taken this photo if it wasn't him? >> I'm
not sure. But I know he was like streaming in the lobby of the
courtroom which probably wasn't a good idea >> Well, that's
inside the courtroom with the way those >> This is inside
the courtroom. But yes, >> that's inside the courtroom.
The way those walls are that's inside because everybody's facing
the bench. >> Well, but where's where's the photo >> I
don't know. That's I was hoping you could tell us like what was
going on here. Like what how did this photo get to anybody? What's
going on?
>> Someone DM'd it to me also, but
>> I'll say it certainly appears like it's inside a courtroom
as of D10. >> I mean it's definitely in a courtroom with
them in the exact
>> inside a court like >> absolutely definitely.
>> The question is whether or not Darius took it, right?
So, I would want to know like basically it got posted in a discord.
Sure. Who posted it in the Discord? Was it Darius or was it somebody
else? Cuz that's what we're trying to find out right now. That's
the big mystery here is
is this from Darius's phone.
>> He's in jail. So, most likely Prawn, have you talked
to you talked to him since he's been in jail or
>> I have talked to him. Yeah. >> What did he have
to say? Like, did you ask him any questions about this? Like,
what was going on? What are his
I didn't ask him about the photo, but um yeah, he's still trying
to figure out exactly what the violation was. He's aware that
he viol violate the order in some way, but he hasn't been formed
exactly what what did that. Uh I think at this point he's like
waiting to hear from a judge. >> He knows. >> I'm
telling you, it's because of him filming Zena in the lobby and
sitting close to her.
My guess was that, but also like just like talking about it before
like the case might have been a violation itself. >> He
didn't have a gag order, so he could have talked about it the
case on the >> I I feel like they might have been ask I
don't know if they have a gag order in this one, but were they
not asking for like him to have to stop talking about it on stream?
I can't remember. Why Why would you think that would be a problem
process that he's talking about it at
>> Maybe it was misinformed, but I heard like that was
that could be a violation of the order itself. just like talking
about it or continuing harassment. >> Him sitting him,
you understand in the temporary protection order, it states that
he must stay a certain amount of feet away from her.
He purposely sits there. Then he gets up, puts his stream on
like his camera stand on the bench in front of him, and he sits
there centered with her on his left side, which is on our right
looking at the at the camera or at the at the stream. Him, whether
he I tell you right now, whether
>> Yeah. Whether he was filming or not, he was sitting
too close to her, therefore violating a temporary protection
order in itself. He was not. So, so he did two things, right?
He streamed her violating the protection order and there was
sitting beside her, right on the other side of her. He's not
supposed to do that. You're supposed to stay away. I don't even
know how many feet. I wish I read the temporary protection order
because it tells Darius how many feets he have to stay away from
Zena. And he sits right behind her knowing she's there. Now,
whether he did this picture, that's just going to add more fuel
to the fire. Oh, there's also uh what this picture as well. Like
he clearly took a selfie with them as well intentionally.
>> This [__]
this this is what I'm talking about. It's like it's like he he's
he wants to go to jail. It's like, "Yeah, lock me up. I'm violating
the temporary protection order."
>> Apparently, he did ask if he could stream in the lobby
and they said yes. >> He had Okay. >> I don't I don't
know if I don't think they knew the whole >> the people
Hold on. Um, let me let me let me ask let me address what you're
just saying. Yes, you can ask to stream in the lobby. As a matter
of fact, let's take this to another place, right? Let's say they're
in um a restaurant, a McDonald's. Let's just say they're in McDonald's
and she he sees Zena at a McDonald's booth and he goes and he
sees her. He literally sees her. He's in the back of her head.
He knows that's her. He hear her voice. And he goes to sit in
a booth behind her. Did he violate the temporary protection order?
>> Yeah, probably. >> Okay. It doesn't matter if
he got
>> I'm saying the fact that he's like kind of trying to
intimidate, right? Like he's he's probably like trying. You could
argue like if you think about the the circumstances gets granted
in like a domestic violence case, like a battered wife and the
husband goes and sits like right beside her, right? Like that's
how the cops will see it, right? Well, that's the reason why
it's going to be permanent because when you're given a temporary
protection order and you're taking pictures and you're filming
yourself and you sit directly behind someone, you're told to
say stay, we'll just say 500 ft, right? We're told that you'll
stay 500 feet. But if you're in good faith and you you don't
have, you know, it's 500 feet is too far, but you stay at least
like uh 100 feet away from her, at least you're trying in good
faith to obey or stay within the the laws of uh the rules of
the temporary protection order. But when you sit directly behind
her and you and you start recording yourself and you start taking
pictures of yourself, you're really just mocking the the temporary
protection order and you also are saying that I'm going to show
her that nothing's going to keep me away from her. That does
not look good to a court judge of a man against a woman.
>> Yeah. I mean, I was saying this earlier. Um I think
he really thought he was like going to win the case. like he
was so sure of himself that I didn't think he thought this would
be initial.
>> That's the only reason that's the only reason I think
he would do this. >> Did he not say he was going >> Just
real quick. Just real quick before you go, Tree, this is actually
the first VOD in the in the courthouse. I thought it was a different
order earlier today, too, but this is the first VOD in the courthouse
is he sit he This is his first stream in the courthouse. He sits
down. He turns it on. Zena is right there. So, you can't really
tell who sat next to who, but he wasn't streaming before that
in the courthouse.
When this turns on in about 5 seconds here, >> it's him
live in the courthouse sitting right beside them.
>> Right. So, this looks so bad. >> Violate. Yeah,
he's going he's going to get permanent. But let me um Oh my gosh.
Can you tell me your name again? I don't >> Prawn. Prawn.
>> You can be Prawn for short. Yeah. >> Prawn. Okay.
So, Pran, um, my thing is is that like I thought he got us a
a lawyer to for today as at $6,000. What happened with that?
>> Uh, I believe that lawyer is for the Merc,
is it not? >> I think that could be the case. Yeah, I think
he for this one he was like just going his own route or like
doing a public defender, but I know he like consult he >> can't
get a public defender for for a civil case, but because he's
in jail, he can possibly get it now cuz you violated a court
order which makes it criminal. So now he can get a public he
could probably get a a public defender. Yeah, like I said, I
think he thought like this was going to be such a like an open
and shut like he was going to win that he thought I think he
thought that Zena like ex exaggerated her claim so much that
they're just going to throw everything out. >> Even if
she did, let's pretend she did. Even if she did, the temporary
protection order must be obeyed.
That is a court order. It's like it's like um it's like child
support. Child support payments are courtordered. All right?
And let's say for instance, you did uh you did give your baby
mama the money, but you didn't document it and she said you didn't
get it, right? You could still go to jail because you can't prove
you gave the money to your baby mama, right? So, you violated
a court order. This is the reason why you're supposed to be doing
things when it comes to child support through a through a uh
a third party so that you don't go to jail for nothing. So even
if he did think that, he still has to obey the court order.
Just like if he if you have to pay child support, you still have
to show documentation that you did give your baby mama and the
monthly pay the monthly payment as ordered by the court. You
have to take these things seriously when it comes to court orders.
>> Yeah. So this looks a little complicated as well, Tree,
because I believe he's also technically on bail for that criminal
charge, right? Like he's he's actually on bail as well for the
Merc >> What criminal charge? >> As far as I know,
he got bailed out for the Merc thing. So he is on bail right
now. So this is him violating the protective order while on bail.
Do you think that complicates things? >> Uh I don't know
the the uh condition.
I think he got I don't know a PR bond for the MK thing. >> I
don't know the conditions of the bond. If the bond states that
you can't if you cannot be locked up for anything
>> I don't know. I don't even know if he's not allowed
to drink. I don't know. I don't know the conditions of the bond
cuz when you get a bond, you are given certain conditions for
that bond. And if you violate those conditions, then you're rearrested.
I don't know what the conditions of those of the bond is. >> He
may not have any. So, if he does if he doesn't have any conditions,
he can he can get arrested for this and it doesn't affect the
bond.
>> See here,
uh personal recgnizance bond. Okay. I wonder if I wonder if it
would even do anything other than just basically he loses his
money for his bond or
>> No, the only way he will lose his money for the bond
if he just doesn't show up for court. And since he's locked up,
he definitely going to show up for court because all they got
to do is go send for him and he'll show up.
But let's say for instance he got court uh let's say for inance
he had court for whatever this is with Merc tomorrow. then the
sheriff for that county or that city will send a uh a prisoner
van to come pick him up and take him to court if the court is
in another jurisdiction.
>> Okay. The personal recgnizance bond is basically he
didn't pay anything so he's just on like basically they're like
oh you haven't violated the law this doesn't affect it just go.
>> Yeah. Okay. >> Yeah. This doesn't affect it then.
>> All right. All right. Somebody asked why would he play
with his freedom like this? This isn't a game. Uh, he's probably
making a lot of money while he's playing with his freedom like
this. Like all the crimes he's committed, >> it's not worth
money. I don't understand why. I I maybe it's a male thing, but
I'm like the y'all talking about money for like he has no freedom
right now. And and and if he's guilty on any of his felonies,
he can't have guns. >> Well, he was making money, but now
he's also now he's got to pay for lawyers. He's got to pay for
like more expensive lawyers now for >> Yep. There we go.
So he now got to spend more money on lawyers because the dumb
ass wanted to violate and be all big and bad. And didn't you
say something about he had tags on his suit? >> Uh yeah,
he kept the tags on his suit. I think said
>> Yeah, they took it off.
>> Oh, damn.
He wanted to return. >> I I think I think he planned to
return that. Yeah, we were talking about that. >> You can't
now because when you take off your suit and you give it to the
sheriff before you put on the Well, they I think they got to
make him take a shower and and make sure he doesn't have any
contraband up his ass. And then they put on he has to put on
the orange suit. They're going to they're going to search that
suit to make sure there's no wire. Um there's nothing there's
nothing uh no contraband in there like no drugs hitting in there,
no uh ease drop e um some listening device in there. And if they
see a tag, they're just gonna take it off. >> Are they
gonna do that for a reason or is that just spiteful like criminals?
>> No, I mean, why would you have like that? They don't
know why would the tags be on there. That's not That's not something
that's normal on a clothes. >> Okay. I was I was curious.
It was just like, yeah, you think you're a security. It could
be also a security thing, too. >> What the tags?
>> I think the little plastic thing that connected to the
tags. If there'd be like a RFID in it or something like just
you wouldn't want anything. Yeah.
>> Honestly, I feel like they just do it as a you like
why is your tag on this? Just like boom off. Done. >> I'll
confirm in a couple days hopefully when he's out. >> Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Um Prawn, did you help him write his >> Uh no,
I did not. It hasn't been very hasn't done very well last 90
bucks. >> He put this picture of you being drunk and trying
to kiss some woman in uh Austin, which is kind of
kind of up to be honest with you.
>> And then the >> Why are you on his GoFundMe? Why
isn't he on the GoFundMe? >> That's a good question, Tree.
Good question. It's almost like he's not taking it serious.
>> He's not taking it seriously. Yeah, that's crazy. >> How
much has he raised so far? >> 90 bucks. >> 90 bucks.
>> How's it going? >> Bucks. No, 90 bucks.
90 bucks. That's what he's got. He's making like $1,000 a day.
I said do not donate to him for this. If you want to give him
subs or something cuz he streams, that's fine. But do not give
him money on this GoFundMe. Do not reinforce that he can like
get bailed out on this stupid crimes misdemeanor. Someone says
maybe. >> Go ahead, Trey. >> That's No, I thought
this the the crime against Merc was a felony.
>> Uh maybe it could be. I'm not sure. Some of these things
can get like charged at different degrees, right? >> Yeah.
One of them is a from He has a felony charge. I remember reading
about it. Chase stock should donate for the future content it'll
bring. No, Darius is much funnier to me when he's poor. I'm sorry.
Like that. Yeah, that's just facts. Okay. Darius is making too
much money now. The content feels like scripted. It's like not
even I It's not stuff I enjoy. When Darius is making less money,
he's funnier to me. >> And I say that purely as a viewer.
Obviously, as a person, I don't want him to be like poor or destitute.
I'm just saying if I want to watch the content all the time,
>> it's way better the other way. >> I thought But
I don't think there's any fel I don't think there's any felonies.
The assault charge is a misdemeanor.
>> Last I checked. >> Fair enough. >> I don't
know. Let me What? What? List all his charges. He had five charges.
>> This is just from this from the American Zeus thing.
There are three charges.
>> Like all the charges he has so far pending. Like like
doesn't he have altogether five charges pending at the
>> Maybe with new ones with Zena with the >> he'd
have three from the Zeus merc thing. He'd have one from Zena
originally and now he's at least got one more, right? >> Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Wait, wait, wait. That's right. The the She did press
charges for the assault thing when he bit her. Correct. Or >> Zena.
Yeah, >> I think it was. >> Okay. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
>> But I don't know if that was a felony. I >> I
don't think so either. I I I could have sworn something with
the merc thing. I could be wrong. I'm I'm open to be wrong. I
thought one of them was a felony if I'm because I thought I heard
him say that when he was asking for donations when he got out
of jail and asked and he asked Merc to he was asking someone
to ask Merc to like not cooperate or or say you're just playing
or something like that. I could be mistaken. I could be mistaken.
>> On the online portal it says misdemeanor but also that
one still has to go to court. So I guess maybe it could escalate
in court. I don't know. >> Okay. I do wonder if like some
of these things become like if it if it seems like he's got the
same charges like piling up. I do wonder if like something there
changes, right? >> He would have to be found guilty or
do a plea bargain with these first char set of charges. And if
he's recharged again, it's a definite
um it's a definite um felony as well as him forfeiting the plea
bargain. And then that's off the table and his original charge.
Uh,
wait a minute. Not the original charge, but I think the um sentencing
with the probation is a violation or whatever. And he goes back
to jail for that, too.
>> Uh, it's not good. None of this adds up to great stuff.
>> I thought that like when people saw how Vitali is getting
right now, but then again, maybe they're thinking like, well,
I'm going just stay out of another country, right? And I know
>> the Philippines is a crazy place to around with that.
>> I know. Like what the is going on with
>> Another black man in America getting by the justice
system.
>> Filipinos voted for a guy who like openly campaigned
on like I have drug dealers before. I literally have scabbed
them in the heart. Like they voted for that guy. I I don't go
to that country and [__] around. Sorry. >> Yeah,
it was deter. Yeah. Yeah. like before the campaign he was like
people like he got asked by reporters like have you like people
he's like yes I have looked people in the eyes and watched them
die it's like what the they voted for that guy for president
it's nuts I would not around that country I would not commit
crimes in that country they got a nicer guy now I think it's
Bong Bong Marcos that guy that guy's nicer but still >> man
I don't know I it's it's crazy I think um I I just don't understand
I I love my freedom I love my life. I love my money and I like
I never even even even
when you're young and dumb like like Darius, I could be using
that money to invest and making that money make money while I'm
sleeping instead of like wasting it on a bunch of lawyers. >> Maybe
this is like 4D chess. He's going to come out here. He's going
to have like 2K viewership. Like he's going to it's going to
work out. >> I think that's that's probably what he thinks.
That's almost certainly what he thinks, right? >> I don't
know. I don't know because um I mean he's not making money as
we speak right now, is he? >> I think he planned to be
home later today. I'll say I'll say that. >> I did not
think he planned for this to go down like that. >> Uh no,
he definitely did not. He um >> Oh, did he have content
planned for today? Do you have like something figured out that
he was going to do? >> Uh I know he's going to prep for
a uh dog kennel stream where he's going to hang out with like
a girl that like acts like a dog and she's going to be in a cage.
So postpone that, I guess. >> No way. No way. It's uh Meline
or something. Is it Is it Meline?
>> Not the famous one now. That's Flexy
>> Okay.
Okay. All right. Fair enough.
>> We were going to go to uh America in Houston, but I
guess not anymore.
>> Wow. America, eh? What do you think about America? Prawn.
You followed any of that stuff?
I was going to go to the Houston event this weekend, but I don't
know if I was saying, have you followed like any of the the stuff
they've been doing so far.
>> The controversy. No, I I don't follow any Tik Tok content.
Should I?
>> Uh, well, I mean, there's funny stuff, but you might
not. I don't know. I I wouldn't advocate it like cringe.
>> Yes. And if you if you I'd say if you're probably interested
in it, you probably would already watched it. It's like not and
people around are being very cringe with Tik Tok people. >> I
seen the crash out that that stuff. >> Oh yeah. You you
kind of know Ry. Yeah. You've probably seen the highlights from
Riyle then.
>> Yeah. Some
do this weekend. All right. Well, uh, good luck with coverage.
I'll let you know if any updates tomorrow. Hopefully I'll be
getting a call from Darius in the morning. >> Yeah, sounds
good. >> Yeah, he's doing PG. Free Darius. Free >> after
the appropriate amount of time. Okay, free Darius.
He could he could sit in jail for a couple nights. Honestly,
it would probably do him well to sit in jail for like 48 hours.
At what point does this guy need to be scared straight, right?
I feel like there's no way he could do well in jail. Although,
I will give him this. Okay, he looks like he might be somebody
who could do well in jail. He's like he looks like a movie character
who's like a hardened criminal a little bit. Okay, there's a
little bit of that there. I can almost
>> but the second he drops this >> by Zena.
>> This is Dan B. So another like I think Dan man B. Dan
he's like another IRL
>> Oh okay. >> He loves jail after that Ice Poseidon
>> Oh yeah. Didn't I say he was going to show up there
with him? I guess he changed his mind, huh? >> Ice did
say that. Ice did say that he'd go and be his lawyer.
Now, I realize I doesn't have the best track record for video
recording where he shouldn't be recording. Okay. But I think
he could have given Darius some guidance here,
>> Wait, what?
No, he could. >> Wait, what? Well, I don't know. I was
just saying I knows how you get in trouble recording where you're
not supposed to record, right? Isn't that what got his entire
Twitch channel nuked? Recording at an airport.
No, I mean, no, he I Well, no, I think he got um I think a lot
of people uh called
and he got thrown off the plane. I can't remember. It's all long
ago. >> Yeah, it's a long time ago. >> Um Trey just
asked, "Ice doesn't like Zena now. What did I miss?" This was
um Zena is Ice Boseidon's girlfriend's
like really close friend. And every time her and Ice Beside get
in a big fight, that's his Ice and his girlfriend. Zena takes
the girlfriend's side and Ice is like sick of it. He like totally
disavowed denounced Zena like was totally like Zena stupid [__]
And
I don't know, maybe when they get back together, maybe he apologizes
to Zena eventually. But I have a feeling it's >> and those
two had it out. Those two had a back and forth also. Zena and
Ice.
>> Wait, when did they have that?
>> Uh when they was on the phone with the the the guy with
the British accent. >> Oh, like on Sam Pepper stream. They
yelled at each other. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They were they
were going back and forth on San Pepper's
>> Oh, but they were they were calling it independently,
weren't they? Did they go Did they go >> No, they was going
back and forth. >> Yeah, they went back and forth. >> She
hung up on them after she made a >> Okay. She does that
quite a lot, actually.
She She does a lot of mic drops. That's kind of Zena's thing.
>> They did. You can never trust streamers like that. that
they'll backstab your ass for clout and an opportunity to get
more uh viewers. Dude, it's never trustworthy. I can you can
never trust
>> They're all like crabs in a barrel.
I would have thought, you know, I are they're not, you know,
maybe maybe >> they're not they're only loyal and you I
guess you I guess you should be loyal to yourself in that type
of situation cuz it's about your own money and everything, but
it's just fake. Your friendship is not
it's really like
Very very conditional.
>> Okay, see that makes some sense to me. Where do we even
go from here? I can't believe like honestly I thought Darius
was going to have a really rough time proving this out in court
if he showed up and was like honest and tried to defend himself
but he showed up. He didn't really have legal representation.
Maybe he got a lawyer's like a consult with a lawyer who told
him like what to bring or something. But it seems like he kind
of cheaped out very seriously because if he did come get consult
from a lawyer they would have said okay here's the thing first
of all stay away from her. Don't sit near her. Okay. And just
basically shut the up and see what she presents and then ask
for a continuation until you get legal
And and if and Darius if Darius never said that on any of his
streams, then he didn't get any legal. >> He did actually
say his strategy was to argue for a continuence.
>> Oh, okay. I didn't know that. Uh then he did talk to
a lawyer because uh that was that would be the only way he would
get a continuous is he say I I'm I'm in the process of getting
funds to pay for a lawyer so I'm going to have to have uh legal
representation so >> it's possible that even getting arrested
he might have gotten a continuence like I don't think it will
go well for him but he might have gotten >> yeah yeah he
would have got it if he if he said if if if one of the reasons
is him saying like for legal counsel the judge would have gave
it to
But the temporary protection order would still stay in place
and he would have got a warning from the judge saying, "I'm going
to give you a continuation,
but the temporary uh protection order stay in place and adhere
to it and then this is the new date and then a court clerk would
give the new court date."
>> Okay.
So, Nati talked to a lawyer. Lawyer told him that he wouldn't
need him at a preliminary PO hearing. Okay. Maybe. I don't know.
I don't know how he
I don't know how he ended up here >> because he's because
he's the one um on the receiving end. He should have showed up
with a lawyer. Okay. Because of the fact that um
he would have told Darius not to do what he's doing right now.
He would have told him like, "Don't sit there. Come over here
and sit here with me and turn and don't have your camera on."
Cuz he's like providing evidence that he violated dumb ass uh
the the the temporary protection order. Uhhuh.
I don't know why you take a selfie here.
That's crazy.
Like all of this is going to be used against him in court. That's
what I'm saying. He's
he is
and and let me this is what I wanted to say. Um so he's she's
going to get there permanent right now. He's when it comes to
streaming. So he's going to have to move somewhere else. I don't
Wait a minute. That does a Does Zena still live if she's living
in Florida? She's living in Texas. >> Uh I think she possibly
lives in Texas >> So if she still lives in Texas, okay,
the only place he can stream is in his backyard.
If he tried to do any collab, if he tried to do any collabs with
anybody that she knows and you know this circle is pretty small,
she's going to show up and now it's going to be more easy to
for him to get arrested than ever that now that the if the the
uh protection order is permanent, >> man. Um
I I don't know how he sits in Texas and like uh I don't know
how he sits in Texas and continues to do this. Apparently Darius
has talked about moving to Arizona. Well, Darius used to live
in Arizona. Rey's in Arizona. Danny's in Arizona. I don't think
he gets along with Danny anymore, though.
>> Aras life will forever go downhill without Rei in it.
For some reason, irrelevant keeps him balanced like a big brother
type of thing and kind of talk some sense into him. Darius is
not that unhinged when irrelevant is within
it's it's within the home. Yeah. Or within the friend group.
But when they're separated like he's so destructive and he just
gets in so much trouble and he's just does a lot of unhinged.
And I know like y'all keep talking, oh he's making all this money.
He's making all this money. He's making all this money. It's
like it's not worth it for I I don't know people like Vitali.
You think Vitali is enjoying all the millions and millions and
millions of dollars he got in the bank? >> I don't think
Vitali was making millions of dollars. But >> no, he has
millions of dollars.
>> No, no, no. Not making people keep forgetting. Vatitali
was a very unless he could. >> Unless Vitality, Unless
Vatelli was reckless with his money, people are forgetting the
millions of dollars he made from his YouTube.
>> People forgetting that like he was a very successful
YouTuber. Now, unless he just spent it all and gambled it all
away, he got millions. >> He also made insane money from
kick before he started doing the IRL nuisance stuff again, right?
Right. >> Like he was doing Well, I guess it was IRL nuisance
stuff, but the pedal hunting on Kick was like going gang busters.
Like he would have been making >> Oh yeah, I forgot about
the pedal hunting, right? Because he he gave My some money to
come join on some of the streams. You know what I'm saying? He
was paying a lot of these people to come on the streams. And
when you can pay people, you know, like a good like a good four
to five digits, you know, you you you're swimming in money. So
like he I'm going to give him the benefit of the doubt and not
think he's a dumbass. All right. Or some pooky who just want
to spend a bunch of money on a bunch of like like um flamboyant
[__] like Bugattis and Ferraris and fake ass Rolex
and like that. I'm gonna assume he has invest his money and put
in a nice cushion, but he can't enjoy that [__] right
now because he's locked up in a dirty ratinfested
sale in the Philippines. So money don't mean if you're sick,
if you're locked up,
all right, or if you're in a
>> But I think Darius is like right there. Okay. He just
needs to get a little bit lucky in court. Okay. It's just like
playing Darius. Okay, you just keep doing the [__]
you're doing and you will get lucky eventually. You'll get found,
you know, not guilty. You'll get released from this protective
order. You just keep on around playing this line. You're actually
going, you're doing decently. Okay. Luck's about to turn. I got
to keep him on the straight and narrow tree. Like the straight
and narrow of >> You're only doing it cuz you want to >> creating
content. Yeah. Yeah. Creating content. Okay. The straight and
narrow. The luck's about to turn, dude. The
>> the Johnny Somali guy is getting in trouble, too. Like
I think you got more charges at it or something. >> I don't
give a [__] man. The South Korean people are acting
like a bunch of They're only doing this. They're not locking
his ass up cuz he's black.
White guilt. South Korean. Why the you going to have white guilt
in your
If that was white, he would have been under the jail already.
>> Oh, say >> okay. Yeah, you probably can. I'm trying
to cut down on the racism. Okay. >> No. Racism lives forever.
Long live
>> God damn it. >> I like racism actually.
>> I I know. I know. Kind of cut down. You know, I could
do a little bit less.
I do a little bit less except against people. Okay. Those people
are doing those people are riding high right now.
They got Mike from PA. >> Anti-semitism.
When the hell you have race? Do you have a lot of black people
on your damn stream? What the hell you talking about? Something
I got to cut down. I sound racism.
Wait, what? What? You don't got no racism on your channel. >> Uh,
Really comes on sometimes. >> Nobody's racist against Really?
>> Okay. Uh, thank God you didn't do the joke that I thought
you were going to >> What joke? >> Nothing. Never
mind.
>> What joke? >> This is not true. This is fake.
This is fake news. Sorry. I don't know if you can see the chat.
>> This is fake news.
>> Said I can't even get him not to call me
>> That's not true. That's not true.
That's not true.
Oh god. Oh boy.
>> A surprising number of black people in the Okay,
I'm not even highlighting that one. That That is not going up
on the stream. That is double fake news right >> Why Why
don't you have Oh, it's because you stream on Twitch is why you
don't put your chat on on on the monitor or >> No, my chat's
on the monitor. My chat's on stream. Oh, but it's on here. >> Yeah.
Sorry. Uh, no, I don't put it on the thing. I could put it in
the thing. Maybe that'd be better for people.
Uh, not funny jokes. Not funny jokes that I'm not doing in the
chat. >> I want to see what they're saying. >> I'm
only going to be here for five more minutes. I I got to get ready
to leave out of here soon.
>> I You know me, I am a I am a crackhead for Darius content.
I just I do enjoy the train wreck. I just can't relate to your
life up for some views and money. I don't know if people love
jail unless you like getting up the ass. I don't understand the
need to go into jail over and over goddamn again. Like what the
>> he doesn't feel safe on the outside anymore after that
Ice Besidon prison stream. He doesn't feel safe on the outside
anymore. Tree. He has to go
>> Okay, that's it. >> Oh, Kger Wick messaged me.
No, no, Wick didn't run. Wick messaged me and just said, "Yeah,
he would talk." I just wasn't sure how to frame I have to figure
out a way to frame the conversation, right? So, I'll see whatever
he says. Sorry, Wick. Uh Wick was so out about Queman. You know
Queman, right? Yeah. You've been on here with Queman.
>> we know >> Wick was What was he doing? He was
like complaining about Queman or something. He said he wouldn't
talk to him. And apparently
I got >> You know each other?
>> Yeah. Quan Queen was the person constantly talking about
Wick stealing money for his um his dental fund. Queen used to
say that Wick Wick stole the the tooth money. Okay. that Wick
Wick ran a GoFundMe to get his teeth fixed and then it took like
it took months and months or something like this.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. So, I think I think Wick did not appreciate that storyline.
Okay.
>> That Queen was running with.
>> So, I think that's why
>> Also, Wick is friends with a lot of people that Quan
doesn't like. And I think that
for some reason I think Quimman like kind of got told, man, am
I remembering this correctly? I think Quimman kind of got like
Lil Brogue by Wick at some point like a year and a half ago,
two years ago. Basically like uh like you you'd be lucky to come
on my stream some like this. I have to go look it up. Don't take
this too seriously, guys, but I do believe like he got told no,
no, I don't have to let you on or something when maybe he'd agree
to have Queen on or something. What am I remember? I'm mis I'm
misremembering. I'll I'll go find it. I'll
>> But I I feel like Wick was like rude and kind of had
blacklisted him like Queen and that
there's some bad blood there. Probably. Probably a little bad
blood. Yeah, we'll see. Does anyone have a time stamp from what
Wick was talking about tonight? Cuz he must have he must have
said Queensman somebody he doesn't want to talk to or the people
around Quean or something about my community. I don't even know.
He said no. He didn't really say anything like that. I said this
is what my chat said. Sorry. I'll just categorize your DMs really
quick. It was something like, "Hey, this is what my chat said,
but I didn't see clips, so I'm not going to take it too seriously,
but if you had criticisms, we could >> He said, "I talked
about Queenman. I don't think I mentioned you, but someone did
ask me if I would talk to you, and I said I would." So, yeah.
So, maybe we'll talk to him. I'm just I'm getting really annoyed
that uh Destiny and Nuts I came to seem to keep implying that
um I'm involved in like doxing or and like they could try to
dox me for this reason or that I deserve to get doxed for this
reason and I keep saying okay make an allegation provide evidence.
Stop saying that like this is happening with no evidence provided.
Right. And the evidence Destiny has shown so far is people like
calling him a loser in my Discord. Yeah. So I'm just I'm waiting
I'm waiting for anything anything serious. I don't think I don't
think you're going to get docs. >> Oh, okay. Well, that's
good to know. Okay, just quick update. I you maybe don't care,
but um I think it had something to do with Brianna Woo. Yes,
I think Queen was like uh wanted to come on to talk to Brianna
Woo or something,
>> It might have had something to do with that or Stardust.
One of the two.
>> Is being a bad
>> Many people are saying this that he's like a self-hating
Jew or something.
Nothing worse.
>> That's the worst kind of dude. Self-hating is the worst
kind of dude
>> Cherry. The Queen and Woo debate is um that was after
the Wick beef. Yeah. >> Why isn't Why isn't uh Cherry in
here? >> Uh I don't know. >> I got to leave in a
minute. But >> she's doing other stuff. She busy, I >> Every
time I come in here,
>> every time you come in here, >> there's no women.
There's no women in >> Yeah, I got no >> [__]
is up with that? What the is up with that, JS? The >> Yeah,
I got no I'm I'm like solo streaming a lot now. I just started
I started solo streaming because I was like, you know what? >> Is
that why every time I want to come in, you're not in your Discord
room where I have permission? >> Yeah, I just I just like
solo streaming all the time now. Yeah, I I do like talking to
you. I do like talking to people in general. No, you don't. Sometimes
they don't cuz you know when you got you know stop lying cuz
when everybody see Darius on your screen you know I'm want in
on this if I happen to see it. >> That was my I literally
just I hopped in Discord immediately when I saw you message cuz
I was like oh tree might want to talk about this.
>> You you shot a message in the chat. I was like oh yeah
for sure Tree would want to talk about this. >> Yeah I
shot a message in the chat because you were not seen in the voice
categories in your Discord.
>> I see. Yeah. I wasn't in any Discord at
>> I don't know. >> I think you're racist. I think
you just don't like me cuz I'm black, right? And you don't want
me here cuz I'm a black woman. So, that makes you sexist, too.
You want to You want to call me the hard R, don't you? Right
now, don't you? >> No, I was going to say the black and
woman makes the talking over me thing happen a lot. So, yeah,
it can be a little irritating. >> You guys could talk over
me. You talked over me the entire time I been here today. The
[__] you talking about? >> The entire time.
>> Oh my goodness. >> N today. Today. Yeah. Y'all
talked over me a lot. I have I had to like
stop before I finish my sentence to let the let the uh men talk.
>> Yeah. Okay.
FM. Dude, do you know who FMJ is? Have you ever had FMJ in your
chat before?
>> No. Uh, what does he look like?
>> Uh, I don't know what he looks like. I just know what
his feet look like because he posted his feet in Discord. >> He's
black. He showed his feet in Discord and people call him I show
feet instead of I show speed.
>> Yeah, that's all I know about him really. I think he's
banned from my Discord technically.
>> Yeah, I literally don't know anything else about him.
>> Show his feet. He showed his feet by taking a picture
of his feet. >> Yeah, for some reason he took a picture
of his feet. Rhinox. Is Rhox still here? Rhinox would have the
picture of the feed. I'm telling you, this guy keeps a lot of
stuff, a lot of records. Okay. Record keeper of sorts. Archavist.
Why do so many foot frogs end up in our Discord? That is an excellent
question cuz I have no love for these people
>> Dude, you want to know what's so crazy? You have so
many freaky people in there that I would appear the normal one
in your Discord. People say this and it hurts me deeply and I
really don't have like a comment or retort to it. So,
yeah.
Yep. Yep.
Okay.
Oh boy.
>> Like all the I've done to men, I would just be like
in your Discord like, damn.
>> Okay. I don't Is that fair? What has my Discord done?
Give me evidence. Don't Don't destiny me right now. Okay. Don't
make a claim with no evidence. What What are you referring to?
What is the freaky thing that's happened? Tree, >> I rather
not go into it because I have to leave it now. And >> to
disclose what I know will require me to stay here an extra 10
minutes >> to list at least half of the freaky
that I know about that goes on in your Discord. By the way, all
legal. None of them includes animals and miners.
>> That's good. Fairies don't count as >> I just
realized that I actually baited basically everybody in the chat
to start posting things they think could count. So probably
probably should have just not said anything.
>> Uh this is probably true. Yes, this is probably true.
>> You said half of them probably include Chris lettuce
or Kger.
>> Yeah, probably.
>> Hey, Chris Lettuce. I know who that is. Of course I
know who Kger is.
Yeah. Have you Have you talked to Chris before in a stream?
>> Um, no. I seen him in my stream in my in my in my chat
and Pretty Tony
and I seen um,
uh, Hooligan
and, uh, if I I I don't want to go into naming everybody, but
I'm just going off the people I can remember off the top of my
head that I've seen. And then captain something. There's another
one who's called captain something. And that comes into my who?
>> Country captain. >> No. No. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. He's one of them. So there are two >> H. Who
would the other captain be?
>> Two captains. Country captain is another one, too. >> I
can't even think of who it would be. >> I want to say Captain
Shepherd, but I think that's wrong.
Anyway. Okay. Um, I have to go.
I um I don't I don't get a like I said I don't get a chance to
see when you're on here talking about Darius. I just finished
my stream. So whenever I finish my stream I see what you're talking
about to see if I can get some content idea
from it >> and then I saw it said Darius arrested. So,
I sat there and I said, "Oh, let me go into the chat." And then
I saw that you said, um,
you know, no allowed, no color section here. White people only.
>> This is a whites only discord right now. >> Yeah.
Like, okay. Yo, I'm not mad though, right? I'm like, okay, I
don't belong here. So, then I went into the
>> where I'm accepted.
>> Okay. And I'm embraced there regardless of my
my race and my gender,
>> my nationality.
>> And I was there >> Americans now. I really do.
I'm sorry. Trump like ruined it. I used to love America as a
Canadian. And I actually like I kind of like actually hate Americans
in a lot of ways now. It sucks. Not in like every way, but it
is actually stupid that like why' that guy do that? Why did he
just like >> Trump Trump saying a bunch of like like you
do know the stupid with the tariffs
is just dumb and it's never going to happen, right? Where they
do they're going to do like 600 something billion investing in
in America like them in the EU don't have that type of money.
It's not going to go through. And then he's going to like, yeah,
I'm really disappointed in Putin, so I'm not going to do them
the 50 days. He got 10 days and I'm going to or I'm going to
tariff China and India.
Then he puts 25% tariffs on India today. Like I could go on and
on all the things he has done. >> but Russia ain't scared,
baby. Russia like we what you do to you can make that [__]
tomorrow then what? >> I think they're pretty economically
isolated already. I don't think economic stuff hits Russia. >> No,
they're not. If they were, the ruble would have been like trash.
And also that let's not forget bricks. I don't know why people
keep downplaying bricks and you got so many countries begging
to be a part of that uh organization.
>> Oh, really? >> And even even with them sanctioning
the out of Brazil, Brazil like you, I got bricks. I can survive
just like like um like uh Russia. And and what it is is like
it's really alienating
um western countries to the point where they're going to slowly
because Trump had already Trump had already um threatened countries
because they see what they're about to do in their future is
that they're slowly going to stop using the dollar. I have not
been paying very much attention to
global economics because this is this all this tariff that Trump's
doing right now is going to affect my money.
You're a Canadian. You guys I think you guys still use wooden
nickels or some [__] like that. I don't give a You're
Canadian. Who gives a [__] what you >> trade
beaver furs belts? That's all we trade. Yeah. >> Yeah.
I ain't gonna about my money as American and like you know and
plus I got investments and like that. I'm like like he's what
I don't want to talk about it. Whatever it is what it is. And
it's like he he he changes he changes his mind based upon who
he talks to
right or he'll say one thing one day then he'll say another.
He's he's such a flip-floppy. He wasn't like this in the first
term. I don't know what the going on here with the second term.
And Miss Lizzy the warhog that she keep talking. And if you don't
do this, China, let me tell you, you are in for a good rude awakening.
We're going to fund all our weapons. Like what weapons? Then
didn't then you guys sell the Pentagon said that we're low on
ammunition and weapons and like that. Then he's gonna sit up
here and say, "I'm gonna sell we're gonna we're gonna sell US
weapons and make NATO buy it so that they can give it to Ukraine."
And I'm like, "You can't make NATO buy it. NATO is not a a complete
entity. It's different countries with inside of NATO." And then
sure enough, the countries in NATO like, "What the y'all talking
about? Y'all can't make us
make us, you know, uh raise our
um what is it called?" when every country has to put certain
a Can you ask your chat what is it called when every country
within NATO >> oh like the um minimum contributions
they put >> yeah they have to give what is that
>> GDP
I think it's just your commitment to >> they have to give
us 30% like anywhere from two to four%
of of their GDP >> unless they're Canada Canada is like
a quarter of a percent Canada is super gay on NATO contributions
Is that true? >> Canada literally always skips out on their
NATO contributions and then the US kind of just goes, "Yeah,
just let us build like radar stations where we want to do." And
Canada's like, "Okay, go >> Yeah, I think it's pretty bad.
I think Canada has missed their like NATO contributions like
decades now. For decades now. >> Holy, dude. You I don't
want I don't want y'all to be a 51st state though. Y'all, dude,
for real.
>> So Mark Carney Oh, I could say this. Mark Mark Carney
has committed to 5% of annual GDP by 2035
to like basically increasing defense spending >> by 2035.
>> Yeah. But yeah, I know before this like under Trudeau
they were like significantly
lagging behind like they were not meeting the 2% at all.
>> Yeah. So not good. So that deal went through because
a lot of the countries were like, "We're not going to we're not
going to raise our contribution just to buy weapons from America."
So it's a lot it's a lot of [__] Anyway, anyway,
I overstayed. See what happened? You got me held here. Let me
go. Set me free. Lose these shackles, massel.
>> Okay. All right.
I don't >> All right. Okay. All right. Um, I will send
you a message the next time if I'm going to do Darius content.
If I like know I'm doing it, I'll shoot you a message and then
I'll be >> Stop being a hiding from me so I can't come
in and join. I don't like that. >> Okay. All right. Well,
thanks for coming on. That was fun. >> Thanks for having
me. Bye.
>> See you. Wow. Wow.
Wow. That's cool. I love when Tree comes on. Okay. Does anybody
have the time stamp for me on?
Oh no.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh. Sorry. I'm just There's stuff, you know,
big things happening everywhere. Big things happening all over
the place. Uh
I just I don't want to lean into this. Seems like inappropriate
to lean into in any way. So I feel very
No, that's not true. That's not true. That's not true. That's
not true. That's not true. That's not true. That's not true.
That's not true. No, no, no, no.
Does anybody know what the Wick was talking about today? That
apparently he's talking about Queen or something. He didn't mention
me or my community, but I was told that it was and then I have
no idea. So,
you guys let me know.
Where are we looking here?
Hold on. I just need to make sure I got all the clips out of
everything that we're going to do. Oh, also had some clips I
think of the Destiny Pisco that like to look over. Might check
that out. Can you not? Can you not? Can you not? Can you not?
Can you not? Can you not? Okay, Ozel had some stuff here. I'm
trying to think of what else I want to do today.
What do we have? I'm I'm pretty much done with the Darius stuff.
I don't think there's anything else to mine there. There's like
the There is this Mercur VOD, but I'm not feeling it to be honest.
I'd rather watch the Mudahar stuff. The Mudahar updates to be
honest with you. I'd rather do the Mudahar stuff. But
but but but oh there's the conversation too. I wonder how long
that goes. Oh, and there's Pisco Avi, too. Me.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I've got the Merc stuff. Creger. I don't know
if I'm going to watch the Merc stuff to be honest with you. Not
right now.
I'm probably actually going to not take another donut for another
hour. I ended up waking up really early this morning. I don't
know if I'm going to stay up late tonight. I just depend.